sollte das aber durch mannschaft läuft
schon high service und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video wissen
heute wieder in unserem garten
das heißt also leute was sebastian sagen
wir wir haben zwei junge herren zu gast
die schiedsrichter
wir haben zwei gäste heute am start
und zwar einmal lang molly und größer
und okay und wir müssen kurz die spieler
erklären ob ihr letztes mit lukas
spielzeug einkaufen und da momentan auch
diese city gekauft
also leute wir stellen uns hier hinter
den handschuh und wer von den jeder
jeweils einmal drei ränge drei versuche
also wir werfen von hier jeder mit drei
ringen auf dieses gestell da vorne und
wenn man genau hinschauen sehen wir was
wie viele punkte bringen kommt darüber
hier ganz vorne zehn punkte 20 20.30
punkt in der mitte fünfzig volle
punktzahl
wir machen einen team ok hier beide sind
in einem team gegen werbe kegel ok
konnte conti bis mein team seien
dokumentiert also ich würd sagen fange
erst einmal an und der captain des
verlierer teams kriegt am ende
diesen ball her wenn er voll gesaugt ist
mit wasser
ins gesicht was soll ich anfangen
sie werfen kannst du da nicht getroffen
jawoll strike es sehr gut das sind
einmal ab 10 10 und 50 60 punkte
verhaftung ist und niemals niemals
niemals jetzt haben die großen jeweils
einmal geworfen
jetzt würde ich sagen dass man die
kleinen noch mal werfen ja aber erst mal
ist er konnte sie erst mal darfst du
erst mal kannst du kommst du mal und
dann schaffst du es kannst du dir inge
[ __ ] aber erst mal kannst du erstmal der
konsti mal nicht wieder ins licht nicht
mehr wo ich nicht drauf zu werden
du kannst du während und noch mal
junge 30 punkte mehr geholt dazu kämen
oregano torres ist okay und triffst du
darfst du wirst geht daneben
20 punkte jetzt noch und jetzt ist mir
noch mal nein ich habe mich wie nach
deinem kumpel
also wir haben uns in der ersten runde
glaube ich 60 punkte geholt das halt ich
60 konsti check-up 30 bauern ihr habt
viel geholt nicht so viel wir haben 40
40 insgesamt oder wir haben 90 konnte
für alle gewinne noch weiter auszubauen
so ein baby oder 90 40 viel dran also
dem 40 uhr 22
aber jetzt achtung marxist marxist
schlecht mag sich nichts der weg von 47
und jetzt willst du nicht noch mal nach
meiner sonst nicht hoffen sie den sieg
jobs sind sie ja das gibt's doch nicht
wir haben ganz vergessen dass conti
natürlich noch mal werfen darf der nicht
mehr geworfen markt geworfen und moore
hat geworfen aber konstanter werfen und
kannst du hast jetzt mit einem lauf
kommt die kunst
jetzt habe ich verloren wurde ja maxi
sand verläuft könnte am ende so gut war
so jetzt muss man nämlich den ballen das
machen sie mehr gleich abbekommen wird
euromax das publikum wartet schon
gespannt darauf ist das bild bei gut was
drin
bis in die entferntesten heute ist aber
irgendwas sagen
heute wird gefeiert und dokumenten rein
wenn es nicht bis zum nächsten mal